[Music]
hello i'm jen wilson senior programmer
and welcome to this film independent
presents q a for the new film tank house
which was a participant in film
independence physical sponsorship
program special thanks to our lead
sponsor hfpa and vision media who hosts
all our virtual screenings and q and a's
now please welcome today's guest from
tank house co-writer and director noam
thomashoff hello producer
hello producer matthew cooper
and actors steven friedrich tara holt
and richard kind welcome everybody
thanks for coming out today
we decided to leave our theater company
asher's nana died after she lived as she
never had before you two are here by
banned from all activities no
this could be our chance to do what
we've always dreamed we are here to
start an artistic revolution there is a
competition for the theater but it's my
ensemble poised to win
this is an active art zone
oh god speak artists can take risks
fail
and bear their open wounds you don't
actually have to hit me
she did the fighting
i've been reading up on leigh who's lead
the founder of the method isn't that
what killed that joker guy so this film
is is um
a comedy about live theater that fertile
place from which many of us including me
have sprung
um
for for noah did you base this movie on
any of your real experiences in the live
theater absolutely this was very very uh
unsubtly based on the experience of
myself and the co-writer chelsea fry
um we both went to theater school and we
you know uh essentially spent the first
couple years out of theater school
really trying to be proper new york
thespians um but the way that manifested
was often you know not certainly not on
broadway but like in the tiny black
boxes around brooklyn and you know the
other burrows and tiny late night
performances and shakespeare outside
um and uh it was an intense
wild lifestyle and tucker and sandrine
essentially were sort of parodies of
ourselves and the people that we had
become living this you know this
lifestyle of uh artistes in the city um
and and so you know essentially the
entire film was uh a love letter an
homage a nod to
the people that we had become living in
that world and then the community that
we were a part of
so uh why did you decide to set the film
in fargo north dakota and is that where
you really shot the movie
yeah so it is definitely where we shot
it and richard came to fargo he can
attest to this
um we spent three weeks in fargo
um
and then a couple days here in la but uh
yeah no so originally the idea for the
story was that these two hyper
pretentious new york thespians you know
weren't able to hack it in the
professional world in new york so they
had to decamp to
a small town uh and that's and it was
really a fictional small town and that
was the uh the conceit in the original
short that we made
of tank house and then when matt cooper
saw the short at a festival he
had the connection to fargo in his head
so he can tell you a little bit about
how that came together
yeah uh
i was looking for a project to produce
and i did have a connection in fargo
north dakota and they were really
looking to
reinvent the art scene out there uh
fargoens are not
overly fond of the movie fargo
and the fact that everyone talks about
it as if it was shot in fargo and none
of it was except i think the exteriors
and so they were really looking for
a new movie to come in and show the
actual
uh town and so i went up to noam in
chelsea after they uh they showed their
short and i just asked them this is
great
i love upstate new york but can we just
make it fargo north dakota instead
and it was that simple that's how it was
born and the really nice thing was that
because the script wasn't written yet we
were able to write for fargo and
incorporate you know real things in town
so all those very sort of visually
unique uh locations that you see like
the troll bar like the theater uh we had
those in mind while we were putting the
whole story together so that we could
feature the town specifically which was
kind of the the remit of the whole you
know movie from the location standpoint
yeah that theater's that theater is
really beautiful uh i i assume it's a
really super it's a pretty old place is
it
like for live theater performances or is
it for also for movies too yeah so it
was from 1924 and actually you know one
of the amazing things about like america
in general is that
the these types of theaters are all over
the place you know between the coasts
because before movies you would have you
know traveling theater performances and
vaudeville and things like this and so
these theaters functioned as like
entertainment centers for the whole
region so in towns like fargo and even
towns smaller than that for example one
that i went to was in hutchinson uh
kansas is filled with these ornate
thousand-seat theaters so i felt like
you know
featuring that and sort of exposing
people to that reality that a lot of
people don't know about was really
important
and to answer your question
yes it does play uh
actual movies
not in 1924 it did not um but we did
we did have a very nice premiere in
fargo where uh we got to really bring we
had a lot of extras from uh the town to
give it uh real shape and and real
authenticity so they got to come to the
premiere we we packed the fargo theater
and it was cool to see the fargo theater
on the big screen and then to literally
look stage left and see
that exact shot that you're watching on
the screen it was cool
yeah it is crazy uh what how many towns
in the us actually had
live theaters or movie theaters i grew
up in a town of 650 people in illinois
in southern illinois
and when i was reading about the history
of the town it had actually had a movie
theater at one time and i was like
what it's crazy it's so crazy
um but a lot of those places haven't
survived sadly
um for for so free the actors
um stephen tara and richard
uh do all of you have live theater
backgrounds and
um
can you sort of talk about what you drew
wrong in your performance history to
create
your characters in this film let's start
with tara
um i actually
have
a limited theater background but i did
go to a performing arts um high school
for acting so i did do theater there um
but very you know elementary
theater
um as i you know kind of went out you
know moved up to la um i only really did
uh like i think one or two small
productions um so it was really
amazing to revisit that that part of
myself because it's a whole different
side
of the art that um
that you know i've been dying to explore
and i was able to you know
include quali like includes shakespeare
and dancing and singing and all these
different aspects into this one you know
film project which was a really
beautiful experience for me
and yeah
it was awesome
great stephen
uh yeah no i grew up doing some theater
in middle school and high school and
then went to college for it at uh north
carolina school of the arts and um then
moved up to new york after that did some
uh shakespeare dinner theaters that i
think i drew the most from for this
performance where you have people with
the largest egos and the smallest
paychecks trying to make the biggest
difference and speak the loudest and uh
be the most important
um but yeah no being surrounded by those
uh those characters
in in work and in play uh to draw from
hundreds of people that i've met
throughout my life that uh
all have that same kind of passion and
drive that will bowl over other people
in pursuit of
of uh that dream was that it was a
really deep well to pull from i've heard
of your shakespeare dinner theater shows
they still talk about that
poisoning that they talk about
there's like a very specific genre of
theater that i feel like that's a part
of which is just like who's the loudest
yeah no it's just we did mid-summer and
uh with the mid-summer night stream like
chaos where they're all drugged and in
the forest and running around and
falling in love with the wrong person
i don't think a single consonant was
pronounced it was just
running around
um
richard
yeah did you say did you start out in
live theater i i
was only live theater for
a decade and a half
uh you know with uh
modicum of
you know
tv
at all i was
my uh off off off-broadway stuff
consisted of a play called take death to
lunch
i did a play called um it's actually
quite a great short play by a great
author arthur copeland who wrote oh dad
poor daddy wrote those uh nine
uh the musical nine uh and became a
friend i couldn't believe it and not
when i did the play play called uh the
day the whores came out to play tennis
and then i met arthur
years later when i was doing a play at a
theater in the hamptons called the bay
street theater and i couldn't believe he
i thought he was this small little guy
like the character and oh dad poor dad
and he was about six four as handsome as
could be he was in the 70s but and i i
when i met him i went oh my god i can't
believe it you and then i did
i did a plays i did uh you know i did uh
summerstock which was 14 shows in 15
weeks and they were big like mame and
lil abner and brigadoon and you know and
we performed every single night and
rehearsed six days a week oh it was that
was a killer
then uh i did second city
uh so that was big
i've done about i think i've done
four or five broadway plays
and and then i do some i you know i
played the guthrie i've been to uh bay
street theater i've done we i've done
five plays at williamstown
uh so i've been that's all i was so i've
met those people
i've been those people
yeah in fact i presently am talking like
those people
i assume you're referring to second city
in chicago
it was what uh what years were you at
the second city
oh let's go and age myself i think i was
there from about
i i think i left in like 89 believe it
or not probably before you were all born
i left in 89 i was there for about about
four years
yeah four four and a half years
you ever hear of practical theater
uh practical
practical theater was started by julia
louis dreyfus and brad hall and oh
and gary kroger and uh uh res pearson
and i i went to school with them and
they started this theater in chicago so
i went out there i did a show for them
called mega fun
and second city uh saw us in that and
recruited and recruited me while they
were on saturday night live i went out
and did that play and then i went to
second city from there
so i was in that for about about four
and a half years i did i did a stint in
regional theater
in chicago in the 90s and tell me
i knew quite a bit of people from from
um
second city and okay what theater did
you do and then who did you know
so i did
i did shows at the baileywick was that
around another baileywick yes i did
shows at the baileywick
um
for the most part i was involved in uh
the bailout was mostly gay productions
so
um i was in mostly like lesbian
productions at
at the bailiwick um but i i went to
second city a lot i knew a lot of people
in second city and in uh improv olympics
right yeah i know all those people
you know that mike hagerty just passed
away did you know mike
no
no
yeah i did it
but who did you know like like dave
pasquazi you know dave
how'd you know don't know if i've known
anybody that went on to become famous
i mean so many of them have
um
so what i loved about this movie is that
you know
you're uh
you're all sort of bonded as an ensemble
the way that a real theater company sort
of bonds to each other like
clue like plato
like something sticky i'm just wondering
how did you accomplish that were you all
staying together
in fargo and just hanging out together
all the time or
yeah i mean you transplant how many
there were seven eight of us
from uh from la or new york to the
middle of uh train tracks and corn
fields and uh there's nothing to do
there but bond so we uh between
filming yeah it was nice to kind of
explore the town get to know each other
um
yeah it just ended up working out really
well that we all ended up
getting along and actually wanting to
hang out there's a lot of times where
you get
to location and everybody just scatters
to their rooms and stays on their phones
but
this was a really really nice unique
experience in the way that we we all did
bond together it felt like a little
theater troupe by the end
yeah a lot of time together um i feel
like
we almost bonded more quickly than the
actual theater company in the in the
movie does we were just like
you know inseparable really
um you know
i'm just kidding well we made it we made
a conscious choice not to have trailers
so that they would have to spend time
together and
i think you had a conscious choice for
other reasons
like who can afford a trailer for a cast
that size
we had a trailer one day one day one day
don't forget that one day
it was in the morning one day everybody
everybody
everybody in an n64 it was luxury
the n64 was what they really had to
spring for unfortunately
what what is an n64 is it a type of
trailer nintendo 64. the oh oh god
okay
like hollywood terminology for trailers
like i'll see you in the n64 like a 347
for a friend
for richard and tara you two have one of
uh my favorite scenes in the movie which
is uh a contest
well actually
stephen was in it stephen participates
in it as well and gets he's just not as
successful
where you have to
sing the lyrics of modern major general
um
uh talk about putting this sequence
together had any of you ever performed
that song
first
no
and then sort of so what were your
preparations like did you have to did
you teach them did you teach them all
the song no gnome
well i mean
yeah i i i it was it was it was a it was
a long process because uh i i didn't
teach it's not like i was sitting there
being like you know do this but we had
to share the lyrics and you know over
time like you give enough of a run-up to
you know wrap your head around like the
style of the operetta um you know
traditionally if this were in the play
it would be like very very proper
british accents but because we were
doing the classic alleyway you know
rumble um
you know we wanted to do it a little
more kind of gritty and like as
themselves
as if you did not me
i was trying to be as english as i could
well
so
so well the way that that translated on
the day is that like you know it's funny
the dp and i had all these crazy plans
about like circular dolly shots of like
you know just beefing it up as this
giant thing but really you know we
it manifested so that we really only had
time to
get the performances as they were
happening because it's very tricky not
only to do it correctly but to also like
have the intention behind it as well
well the day the day that we showed up
the
location that we had scouted we showed
up and there was this hum
of electricity above the location so we
had to move everything that morning so
what noam was talking about it really
was
uh
it was thrown
thrown together uh and i think that's a
real testament to the three actors i
didn't know
no you ask how do you prepare for that
you study and you study and you study so
that it comes out of your mouth like pea
soup out of linda blair
without
and that's what you have to do that is
your preparation you don't get into
character you just know the words that's
the and it's hard and it's really hard
to do it at the speed that gnome wanted
it and that the script demands but you
just study it and you better have it
yeah they put some earpieces in with a
little bit of a like a tempo click track
for us and uh and i realized you know
after years and years of being told you
know men can't multitask i can't i can't
do it i can't have a tempo and keep it
up at the same time so it was a i don't
want to say the most challenging thing
in my career so far but it was
by the time i got the ear the clicking
in my ear it was like i had to just
throw it out the window
it was the very first thing that i
started memorizing when i when i booked
the project um because i was terrified
of it and i watched a video after video
after video but none of them were doing
what we're doing in this scene you know
they were just performing it and so i
had to kind of also throw that out the
window and sort of see what i wanted
to do to bring the thing home
um which also last minute noam like
corrected me on all these things so it
was a yeah it was a challenging day but
like we
you know handled the task
well i i did i did the producers on
broadway
and
there are two moments where max has to
do i mean i could do i i knew it so well
that i did they're a gal opening night
again you'll see your name in lights
again you'll go from doctor bryce again
your spirit how your sketch again you'll
never suffer slightly again i'll take
those with the lights again
now i did that easily six to ten years
ago you just sort of
do you know that
and then he has a song called betrayed
which is a monologue that that uh i
don't remember that as well uh where you
go over the whole story of the producers
so
yeah you learn these things
yeah yeah exactly well it turned out
well i laughed hard it's very it's very
funny and i have to admit i i enjoyed it
while i was doing it i never thought it
would be i thought it was a very funny
conceit
but you just sort of put yourself in the
director's hands and say go ahead i'll
do what you want what do you need but i
didn't think i thought it was funny but
i didn't think it was as funny until i
saw it it was hilarious very well shot
and it really had that west side story
feel that uh i thought it would happen
it's very funny
yeah it did
thank you yeah i mean and one of the key
things about it like in in it you know
what happens is that richard sort of
like
uh you know goes full tilts to stephen
and steven sort of interprets that all
the lines as physical blows
um and then he gets a nose lead
uh so you know i i think the most
important thing like you know on a high
level that's happening there is is like
we're reinforcing that this world like
is a different world like in this world
like you know you can you can make
someone physically fall over from doing
this song really fast so i think it just
like helps the audience be like you know
it helps sell the the all the other
conceits in this world which is like
more of a whimsical world but normal
rules don't you always apply
so for richard
you played the kindest sort of villain
in this film
um
have you played a lot of villains do you
like playing villain morton
your character is morton is it fun
playing the villain
is it more yeah
it is i i got to do a play i play on
broadway called the big knife by
clifford odette where the guy is i uh
based on uh harry cone a studio boss i
love it
oh it's so good it's so good and it's
being really villainous is is a lot of
fun
there are
there
when i did this
movie
and i didn't know this would happen
because i always think that the answers
are in the script
uh
there are three
different styles of acting
that i
did without really knowing it or or
certainly planning it but when i meet
these two
i'm a little
i i don't want to say i was embarrassed
by my performance but i was over the top
with a very you know what what gnome was
talking about the very literate and uh
you know uh
what what's the word you used about the
actors so so for um but i can't remember
what but anyway
what would you say not pretentious yes
pretentious i had to act very
pretentious in order to do it i had this
you know sort of this accident like that
and then during the movie itself
i played a villain
you know like i'm hanging behind the
garbage cans and figuring out
and i'll get them and stuff like that uh
which has nothing to do with pretension
it has to do with setting up the
villainy so that we can tell the story
and that they have
uh atta an antagonist and then there's a
the scene at the end that's on the stage
with the young girl and saying this is
why i am and that has nothing to do with
villainy that was sort of a
self-reflective yeah you know for me it
was a real only uh
uh emotional moment
in the movie for me and you cut some of
that didn't you know that did not stay
in
uh the full
uh the full seat didn't
the one on stage i mean it's mostly
there there's maybe a little a few cuts
but
all right but anyway that was where i
had to
speak from the heart rather than play a
part
so there were really three different
types of of acting styles that i had to
do
as the movie progressed
[Music]